i recently set up a uh a simulator rig
which i'm hoping to use more on my
twitch streams uh
just to get more sort of seat virtual
seat time like it's not as good as the
real thing
right right but it's still pretty good
like it just you have like the steering
wheel like
yeah i got the floor i got the steering
wheel all the pedals the
little seat and the rack and everything
yeah it goes on yeah yeah it's good uh
it it's it's go it's at a stage now
where you can use it as a fairly good
facsimile of the real thing
not not so much as the feeling but just
the um
concentration mindset like a combination
of like movements yeah like you can
practice your like because you know that
like
there's your tracks irl and there's
tracks in-game so i can watch the video
of me at the track
and then go in the simulator and go okay
i keep doing this here
i've got to unlearn that because then
you just hit the reset button back just
back to start back to start
you know screw it up okay back to start
let's try it again okay got it and you
just
get that muscle member that's the future
isn't it yes i mean it's kind of like if
you think it's like a sort of a it's
like a speed run
if you think about it you know like all
drifting in future will be done
virtually
drifting speed dude there are entire
virtual drifters i've
seen i've seen yeah drifting
competitions and they're serious man
they're so
yeah i went in the comp once i just went
in sort of as a joke and i just made
a huge ass out of myself i crashed off
the start line
it was yeah it's it's serious and how do
the virtual ones compare to actually
doing the real thing though
in in the sense of what they do in there
it's like almost the same
oh wow the way the way they drive uh i
mean even like there's things like eye
racing and stuff where it's like
it's a full-on nascar race and it's run
at like the same
sort of schedule as the real thing right
but it's just not real so here's the
thing
here's the thing though some some
drivers who are really good in the game
have tried doing it irl and they're just
like i can't do it it's just too
it's too scary oh yeah it's got a lot
more forces yeah
there's the g-forces also the fact that
if you could die
yeah yeah yeah stereotypically crash and
get hurt like ah
and every suit like i said before like i
saw a guy come off the track hit the
wall like
at an oblique angle was it okay huh was
he okay no he broke his uh he broke his
leg and his ribs
yikes i'd rather that than a [ __ ]
sticker on my card
which
stickers that do not peel off as well
this is my [ __ ] nightmare
it's like industrial glue stickers don't
[ __ ] come sorry
are we still on the sticker
so how often do you stream on twitch oh
god don't ask my subs that they're very
angry
i used to do a lot more regularly but
then like when um when the rona happened
i thought like everyone else did
oh this free time yeah i can i can get
back into it properly
no yeah that never happens it just made
it even worse um
my aim is like twice a week i want to do
some more like sim stuff also irl my my
next goal
is to do a full track day as an irl
stream now what's
your twitch i've sort of what's that
what is your twitch it is unfortunately
it's noriero japan
check him out check him out add that on
the end there but uh yeah it's uh
it's mostly car related stuff uh like
either
either car games like my summer car or
other sort of
indie games and stuff like that but i
also want to do more irl stuff
uh now that all this sort of stuff is
started calming down yeah track days are
running again
i want to get like a you know the
backpack all that sort of stuff and do a
full track though i can't do really well
yeah
all of my if you look at if you sort my
highlights like all the
biggest highlights are all stuff
[Music]
the best thing about that is like it's
you don't know what's going to happen
yeah yeah i can crash in every corner
they're all waiting there
but then sometimes something really cool
happens like i think i was in a car
actually with sunaga the guy you rode
with yeah right at eb
soup i was riding passenger and he got
like within a millimeter of the car in
front we're doing like first gear
and chad is just going nuts
[Laughter]
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening it was insane
the man was insane because i'm
absolutely legend i remember
i remember when we were like learning
the handbrake turns and just like that
one session gave me like the [ __ ]
worst wanker's cramp i've ever like felt
in my life
it's good i've never heard of this
because it's the same kind of movement
right god
i've never had to crank it like that
hard and it just it just was a movement
that my arms
weren't used to man what can i say oh my
god but it was it was fun as hell that's
that that's a normal thing though you do
get
also you you hurt your hand right yeah
let me tell you okay never never put
your thumbs inside the steering wheel
yeah that's i think that's exactly what
that's i think he was scared to death so
he was great
no no i i guarantee you that's what
happened is because what you do is you
put your hand
your thumb inside the steering wheel
yeah and then when it counter steers
yeah the spoke of it comes around and
wangs you on the on the on the fingers
yeah yeah
that happens a lot that's exactly yeah
because that's exactly like now that i'm
thinking about it like if i was holding
it like this
where i injured myself is exactly where
that spoke was yeah it's a really good
they should have told you that
it's come on [ __ ] i mean i
i didn't think we were going fast enough
to [ __ ] matter to grip onto the thing
i was like
you know like well sorry that you're a
[ __ ] nasty we were going slow
we did you didn't have to hold on i've
never driven a manual give me a [ __ ]
what do you think the car was gonna go
chewie what a [ __ ] no i'm scared